Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
DANIELLE FACED A TOUGH DECISION
ABOUT THE GAP IN HER TEETH.
IT'S EITHER YOU CLOSE YOUR GAP
OR YOU GO HOME.
AND CHOSE TO TAKE
HER SMILE TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
- WHAT YOU GOT NOW?
- OH, MY GOD.
I DRAGGED IN A TYRA LOOKALIKE
TO HELP ME ANNOUNCE
A BIG SURPRISE.
I THINK THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO SETTLE THIS
IS TO GO TO THAILAND!
(screaming)
IN THEIR FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT ABROAD...
THE IDEA OF THE SHOOT IS
YOU'RE UPSIDE -DOWN.
SOME OF THE GIRLS WERE GORGEOUS
CREATURES FROM UNDER THE SEA.
SOME WERE JUST ALL WET.
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
CAN I GET A DIFFERENT FACIAL
EXPRESSION.
THERE YOU GO.
THE JUDGES SAW NNENNA'S
POTENTIAL HIT A PLATEAU.
SHE NEEDS TO REALLY SORT OF
RAISE THE BAR AND SHE'S NOT.
I THINK NNENNA IS SINKING FAST.
- AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
- THANK YOU.
FIVE GIRLS REMAIN.
JADE, JOANINE, DANIELLE,
FURONDA, AND SARA.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ YOU WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪♪♪
MY FAVORITE QUOTE
THAT I LIVE BY IS,
"WHAT WE DO DOES NOT DEFINE US,
WHAT DEFINES US IS HOW WELL
WE RISE AFTER FALLING."
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
LAST WEEK WITH NNENNA.
BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO PUTS
YOU IN A VULNERABLE POSITION
BECAUSE IT'S FRESH
ON THEIR MINDS.
THIS IS THE GIRL THAT
WE ALMOST SENT HOME LAST WEEK,
SO I HAVE TO PULL IT TOGETHER
SO THAT I WON'T BE
IN THE BOTTOM TWO AGAIN.
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN MYSELF,
BUT I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE YET WITH MY MODELING,
SO I NEED TO ALMOST FAKE
A CONFIDENCE IN MY MODELING
UNTIL I REALLY FEEL IT.
DESPITE EVERYTHING,
YOU KNOW, I WISH YOU WELL
- AND I WISH MYSELF WELL.
- YEAH, YOU TOO.
I COULD SEE YOU BEING VERY
DEMANDING, LIKE, THAT'S--
I CAN SEE YOU BEING
A LITTLE TWO-FACED.
I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE JADE'S
A GOOD PERSON ON THE INSIDE,
AND I THINK THAT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
NEEDS TO BE SOMEONE THAT OTHERS
CAN TALK TO, LOOK UP TO.
BUT IN A TWO-FACED IN SUCH A
NEGATIVE FORM, BUT JUST LIKE...
YOU DO DEFINITELY
HAVE A MOTHER INSTINCT.
JOANIE JUST DOESN'T
STRIKE ME AS A MODEL
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE IF SHE W
AS PUT IN A POSITION
TO GO TO CASTINGS IN NEW YORK,
I THINK THEY WOULD
LAUGH AT HER.
SHE DOESN'T
SCREAM MODEL TO ME AT ALL.
♪♪♪
BEING IN THIS COMPETITION,
IT CAN GET KIND OF LIKE,
DRAINING,
SO I WOULD JUST PICK UP MY BIBLE
AND READ A COUPLE SCRIPTURES
TO GET ME BACK TO THAT POINT
WHERE I NEED TO BE.
TYRA MAIL!
"YOU WILL FIND YOURSELF IN
A STRANGE POSITION TOMORROW,
TYRA."
MAYBE WE'RE
GONNA BE IN A CIRCUS.
MAYBE.
♪♪♪
(engine starts)
WE HAVE DONE SO MUCH.
BUT IT'S CONSTANT,
WE BEEN DOING STUFF,
DOING IT, DOING IT, DOING IT.
GO TO SLEEP AT 2:00,
WAKE UP AT 6:00.
FURONDA, I THINK SHE'S PUTTING
TOO MUCH THOUGHT INTO IT,
AND SHE'S KIND OF LIKE CHOKING.
YOU KNOW, I THINK SHE JUST NEEDS
TO KIND OF, LIKE, CALM DOWN,
CHILL OUT,
YOU KNOW, FOCUS, REGROUP.
(speaks Thai)
WELCOME TO
THE PATRAVADI THEATER.
MY NAME IS PATRAVADI MEJUDHON
AND I'M THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR
AND THE FOUNDER OF THIS PLACE.
I'M GONNA BE TEACHING YOU
THAI CLASSICAL DANCE.
AS MODELS, YOU HAVE TO EXPRESS
WITH THE FACE AND THE BODY.
MAYBE THE MOVEMENTS
OF THAI CLASSICAL DANCE
WILL ENHANCE YOUR ABILITY
AS MODELS.
BEFORE YOU LEARN
THE THAI CLASSICAL DANCE,
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO WATCH
HOW THEY PERFORM.
♪♪♪
WATCHING THE THAI DANCERS
IS BREATHTAKING.
THEY'RE VERY PRECISE.
THEIR WRISTS, ARE, LIKE,
BENT, LIKE, BACK TO HERE.
WE'RE GONNA GO AND INTO CLASS
AND LEARN ALL THIS.
NOW I WILL TEACH YOU
THE FIRST GESTURE.
THIS IS A JEEB.
ALWAYS BEND THE WRIST
ALL THE WAY BACK.
VERY ELEGANT,
VERY BEAUTIFUL, VERY STRONG.
I'M NOT FEELING GOOD RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE A REALLY BAD MIGRAINE,
AND LIKE, YOU GET SICK,
BUT YOU HAVE TO KEEP GOING.
THE JEEB CAN BE FLOWERS.
IT CAN BE THE BIRD.
IT CAN BE ME, I AM.
THE MOVES WERE VERY INTRICATE
AND THEY'RE TELLING A STORY,
SO THERE'S A LOT OF
TRICKY THINGS INVOLVED
WITH THAI DANCING.
LOVE AND SHYNESS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THE IMAGE OF THE HANDS,
IT'S GOOD LOOKING IN THE CAMERA.
FOR WOMEN, THE HANDS NEVER GO
HIGHER THAN THE EYES.
FOR THE MEN,
COULD GO TO EYEBROW.
THANK YOU, PATRAVADI,
FOR LETTING ME KNOW,
'CAUSE THAT'S NOT
WHAT I AM AND--
I DON'T HAVE AN OUNCE
OF ARROGANCE IN MY BODY.
GROW.
I THINK MY BIGGEST WEAKNESS
IN THIS COMPETITION
IS POSSIBLY MY NERVES.
I DON'T RETAIN INFORMATION
THAT QUICKLY,
ESPECIALLY DANCING,
SO I'M KIND OF CONFUSED.
TO BE ANGRY.
(sighing)
USE THE BREATH.
AND...
(sighs)
YEAH, ANGRY.
VERY ANGRY.
(sighing)
WALKING.
HEELS DOWN.
KEEP YOUR FEET VERY CLOSE
TO THE FLOOR TO BE POLITE.
HOLD ON,
I'M NOT UNDERSTANDING.
AND KEEP YOUR BALANCE.
ALWAYS STAY UP STRAIGHT.
SLIDE YOUR FEET ON THE GROUND.
WALK FASTER.
AND KEEP WALKING LIKE MODELING.
LEAVE THE BODY THE SAME.
YES.
VERY RELAXED.
ALL RIGHT, WONDERFUL.
THE FARTHER ALONG WE GO,
AND YOU KNOW,
LEARNING THE DANCE,
EVERYTHING BECOMES
REALLY FAINT TO ME,
IT'S LIKE, ALMOST LIKE
AN OUT-OF-BODY EXPERIENCE.
YOU'VE LEARNED A LOT TODAY
AND I'LL GIVE YOU TIME
TO PRACTICE.
BE CREATIVE, BE BEAUTIFUL,
BUT NOT ARROGANT.
- THANK YOU.
DANIELLE HAS BEEN
FEELING WOOZY ALL DAY.
SHE'S SUCH A STRONG PERSON
AND TO REALLY,
REALLY SEE HER NOT LOOK WELL
IS JUST A SIGN TO ME THAT
SOMETHING'S REALLY WRONG.
DANIELLE IS JUST LIKE,
"I'M NOT IN THE MOOD
FOR NONE OF THIS."
BUT YOU GOTTA HAVE
FUN WITH IT, RIGHT?
SO WE GO EAT LUNCH,
AND I'M LIKE,
"I THINK I HAVE SOMETHING."
I CAN HEAR THEM TALKING.
I WAS KIND OF LIKE IN AND OUT.
YOU KNOW, I DO RESPECT EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU
FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN,
OKAY, JADE?
WHAT, MAN, WHAT?
NO, SERIOUSLY, LIKE,
I DO AND I--
I DON'T KNOW, MAN.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU THINK OF ME.
YOU'RE ALWAYS DEFENSIVE AND--
- I AM NOT!
- YEAH, AND I DON'T--
- TO WHO?
- TO EVERYBODY.
NO, THAT'S LIES.
"PEOPLE ARE PERCEIVING ME
THIS WAY."
AND, "NO, I'M NOT, NO,
I'M NOT, NO, I'M NOT."
- ♪ LIES. ♪
- LISTEN TO YOURSELF, THOUGH.
JOANIE IS REALLY JUST TRYING TO
CORRUPT THINGS, I THINK, FOR ME.
YOU'RE SO DEFENSIVE, JADE.
GIRL, I AM--
WHY ARE YOU GETTING UPSET?
I'M NOT GETTING UPSET.
YEAH, 'CAUSE YOU'RE LIKE,
YOU KNOW,
WHY ARE YOU GETTING
SO DEFENSIVE.
WHEN JADE AND JOANIE GET
TO ARGUING, TO ME,
IT SOUNDS LIKE,
WOMP, WOMP, WOMP, WOMP, WOMP.
WOMP, WOMP, WOMP.
I WAS TRYING TO TUNE THEM OUT.
IF ANYBODY EVER
SPEAKS ABOUT YOU.
YOU'RE PERCEIVING ME,
SOMETHING THAT I'M NOT,
- BUT I BRUSH IT OFF.
- YOU BRUSHING IT OFF?
YOU DON'T THINK YOU NEED
TO CHANGE ANYTHING?
- ARE YOU TYRA?
- TO CHANGE ANYTHING?
- ARE YOU TYRA, JOANIE?
- I'M JUST SAYING.
I DON'T THINK JADE
RESPECTS ME AT ALL.
IF THERE WAS ANY IOTA,
I WOULD FEEL IT, BUT I DON'T.
EVEN WHEN I SIT NEXT TO HER,
ALL I SMELL IS JUST BITCH.
(sobbing)
(groaning)
MY WHOLE ENTIRE BODY WAS NUMB,
IT'S LIKE MY LIPS WERE NUMB,
MY EYES WERE TWITCHING,
MY WHOLE ENTIRE BODY
WAS SHAKING.
(groaning)
RIGHT NOW, I'M REALLY NOT
TOO MUCH WORRIED ABOUT
THE COMPETITION,
I'M WORRIED ABOUT MY HEALTH.
I'VE NEVER BEEN IN
A HOSPITAL BEFORE,
I DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING TO ME,
SO IT'S REALLY SCARY RIGHT NOW.
SHE WENT--
SHE'S GOING TO THE DOCTOR.
DANIELLE'S GONE TO SEE A DOCTOR.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WRONG
RIGHT AT THIS POINT,
SO WE'RE JUST PRAYING
THAT SHE'S OKAY.
WELCOME TO THE THEATER
IN THE GARDEN.
THIS AFTERNOON,
I'D LIKE TO PUT YOU IN A TEST,
SO YOU ALL GONNA BE DANCING
ON THIS STAGE.
I HAVE INVITED SOME AUDIENCE
AND THREE OTHER JUDGES.
DANIELLE NOT BEING
PRESENT FOR A CHALLENGE,
IT MIGHT NOT BE A GOOD THING
WHEN SHE GETS IN FRONT
OF THE PANEL.
THERE'LL BE DRUMMERS
AND THAI MUSICIANS
AND WE WILL HAVE ONLY
ONE WINNER, UNFORTUNATELY.
THIS IS A GREAT TEST FOR US,
BEING A TOP MODEL,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO TRAVEL
THE WORLD,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO LEARN ABOUT CULTURES.
BEAUTIFUL!
THIS IS FABULOUS.
LOOK AT THIS STUFF.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
- WHAT FUN.
- WOW.
LA-LA-LA.
PERFORMING IN THAILAND.
- IN THAILAND.
- CLASSICAL THAI DANCE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
LAST WEEK.
I GOTTA AMP THIS UP
LIKE A THOUSAND PERCENT.
THIS IS FUN,
IT'S LIKE HALLOWEEN.
WOO-HOO!
JADE WON, LIKE, SIX TIMES.
I JUST GET SICK OF HER WINNING.
I JUST WANT
TO WIN SOMETHING.
FOCUS.
(crowd applauds)
♪♪♪
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE
TO SEE US TODAY,
AND THEY'RE ALL THAI PEOPLE,
SO OBVIOUSLY, THEY KNOW HOW
THIS DANCE IS SUPPOSED TO GO.
♪♪♪
I KIND OF SEEM LIKE
I FIT THE IMAGE OF THAI,
IT'S TRIPPING ME OUT, MAN,
IT'S TRIPPING ME OUT.
SO I'M EXCITED.
♪♪♪
I THINK JADE TRIES TO BE
VERY ORNATE AND PRECISE,
BUT SHE NEVER SMILED, EVER.
♪♪♪
JADE LOOKED QUITE UNCOMFORTABLE.
HER EYES LOOKED
QUITE WORRIED.
♪♪♪
(audience applauds)
I'M HERE IN MY LITTLE POSE,
I THINK I'M GONNA DO REALLY GOOD
AND THEN ALL OF THE SUDDEN,
I START SHAKING.
THIS IS WHEN I KNOW
THE ADRENALINE IS KICKING IN.
♪♪♪
I'M WATCHING JOANIE,
I'M LIKE, WOW, SHE'S REALLY
DOING A GREAT JOB,
BUT I'M NOT INTIMIDATED BY HER.
SHE'S JUST NOT ON MY LEVEL.
♪♪♪
JOANIE.
SHE'S VERY POISED,
VERY ELEGANT.
I LIKE THE SMILE
ON JOANIE'S FACE.
♪♪♪
I DID THE BEST THAT
I POSSIBLY COULD,
AND I'M REALLY,
REALLY PROUD OF MYSELF.
♪♪♪
I DEFINITELY HAD A HARD TIME.
I WOULD TRY AND GET
THE RIGHT BODY LANGUAGE
AND THEN MY FACE
WOULD, LIKE, STRAIN.
♪♪♪
SARA IS BEAUTIFUL.
IF SHE BE MORE CONFIDENT
IN WHAT SHE WAS DOING,
SHE WILL DO MUCH BETTER.
♪♪♪
I DON'T THINK THAT I HAVE
A CAREER IN
TRADITIONAL THAI DANCE.
RIGHT NOW,
I'M FEELING A LITTLE NERVOUS.
I'M THINKING, YOU KNOW,
"I DON'T REMEMBER TOO MUCH ABOUT
THIS THAI DANCE,
BUT I'M GONNA DO MY BEST."
♪♪♪
AT THIS CHALLENGE,
ONCE AGAIN,
MY NERVES HAVE TAKEN OVER
AND THE THINGS THAT I KNOW
I SHOULD BE DOING
KIND OF GO OUT OF THE WINDOW,
AND I JUST GO OFF
ON THIS TANGENT OF WHATEVER.
♪♪♪
IT WASN'T ANYTHING THAI,
IT WAS HULA, IT WAS CLUB,
IT WAS EVERYWHERE.
♪♪♪
FURONDA IS GOOD IN ENTERTAINING,
BUT SHE NEEDS TO BE
MORE DISCIPLINED,
AND SHE SHOULD PAY ATTENTION
MORE IN THE TECHNIQUES
AND THE KNOWLEDGE.
♪♪♪
(audience applauds)
WHOO!
HERE, KITTY,
KITTY, KITTY, KITTY.
THANK YOU FOR
THE GREAT PERFORMANCE.
I LIKE TO INTRODUCE THE JUDGES.
THIS IS SIRITHORN SRICHALAKOM,
SHE'S A PROFESSOR IN DANCE.
PETRA SRIWARANON, HE'S A VERY
FAMOUS THAI CLASSICAL DANCER.
SIRI UDOMRITTHIRUJ.
SHE'S A GROUP PUBLISHING
DIRECTOR FROM ELLE THAILAND.
ALL THE JUDGES HAVE AGREED
THAT THE WINNER IS...
JOANIE.
(cheering)
YAY.
YAY!
IT MAKES ME FEEL GOOD
TO HAVE THESE FOUR THAI PEOPLE
WHO KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
WHAT I'M DOING
TELL ME THAT I WAS
THE BEST AT IT.
THAT WAS COOL.
JOANIE, PLEASE PICK A FRIEND
TO SHARE YOUR PRIZE.
SARA'S NEVER WON ANYTHING, SO...
THANKS, JOANIE.
THANKS, APPRECIATE IT.
I'M HAPPY THAT SHE CHOOSES ME,
BUT IF YOU'RE GONNA CHOOSE ME,
CHOOSE ME BECAUSE
YOU WANT ME TO GO,
NOT BECAUSE YOU FEEL
SORRY FOR ME.
WELL, TONIGHT, JOANIE AND SARA
WILL BE DINING WITH SIRI.
OH.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU ALL.
I'M THINKING ABOUT THE GIRLS.
THEY'RE PROBABLY DANCING
RIGHT NOW,
AND I'M SITTING UP HERE
WITH AN IV IN MY ARM.
I JUST GOT DEHYDRATED
REALLY BAD.
THE DOCTORS WANT ME
TO STAY IN THE HOSPITAL.
I KNOW I PROBABLY SHOULD STAY,
BUT THERE'S NO WAY THAT
I'M MISSING THE COMPETITION.
- HI, YOU GUYS.
- HI!
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU OUT
OF UNIFORM AND OUTFIT.
- HI.
PLEASE, SIT DOWN.
YOU GUYS TIRED?
THAT THAI DANCING
TAKES A LOT OUT OF YOU.
YES.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU SOMETHING
FIRST AS--
FOR DANCING SO WELL.
- VERY TRADITIONAL THAI.
- WOW, THANK YOU.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
I AM GOING TO PUT
MY WARRIOR HEAD
ON THE COFFEE TABLE,
BECAUSE THAT WAY,
IT WILL BE STARING BACK
AND JADE.
AND SHE WILL KNOW THAT THERE
IS A WARRIOR LOOKING AT HER
ALL THE TIME.
AND THIS IS ME.
WHY DID YOU GUYS
WANT TO BECOME MODELS?
WHAT INSPIRED YOU?
I ACTUALLY HAVE
NO MODELING EXPERIENCE
COMING TO THIS COMPETITION.
SO HOW DO YOU LIKE IT SO FAR?
IT'S DEFINITELY NOT JUST ABOUT,
YOU KNOW,
BEING A PRETTY FACE
AND GOING OUT THERE AND SMILING.
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO IT.
YOU HAVE TO, I THINK,
ALWAYS BE AWARE
OF THE REPERCUSSIONS
OF WHAT YOU DO EACH DAY.
KEEP IN MIND WHO YOU ARE
AND HOLD YOURSELF VERY,
VERY WELL.
I HOPE WE CAN KEEP IN CONTACT
AND IF YOU COME BACK TO
THAILAND, WE'RE HERE,
SO CAN YOU ALWAYS CONTACT US
AT "ELLE".
TYRA MAIL!
"BURN YOUR BIKINIS, YOU'LL HAVE
TO ROCK IT IN A PAIR OF TRUNKS."
DANIELLE.
WE LEAVING IN ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES.
MY WHOLE ENTIRE FACE IS HURTING.
I'M NOT WELL,
AND I KNOW THE REASON WHY
I'M FEELING LIKE THIS
IS BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
I LEFT THE HOSPITAL AGAINST
THE DOCTOR'S ORDERS.
I'M NOT IN ANY KIND OF SHAPE
TO DO A PHOTO SHOOT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S TIME TO GET UP, BABY.
I'M BATTLING WITH MYSELF
BECAUSE I DO WANT TO THROW
MY HANDS UP AND JUST GO HOME.
♪♪♪
I WAS JUST IN THE HOSPITAL
THE NIGHT BEFORE.
I'M SUFFERING FROM EXHAUSTION,
ALSO DEHYDRATION AND A LITTLE
BIT OF FOOD POISONING.
I'M FRUSTRATING ABOUT
LEAVING AND MISSING A CHALLENGE.
I HAVE TO JUST DIG DEEP WITHIN
AND PULL THAT DRIVE OUT OF ME.
IF DANIELLE DOESN'T MAKE IT
TO THE PHOTO SHOOT,
THEN SHE'S PROBABLY GONNA
HAVE TO GO HOME.
IF IT'S TOO MUCH FOR YOU....
(elephant trumpets)
(cheering)
- GOOD MORNING.
- WHAT'S UP?
SEE HOW I GOT TO WORK TODAY?
(elephant trumpets)
ISN'T THIS COOL?
COME HERE, BABY.
SO CUTE.
TO BE NEXT TO A CREATURE
THAT PREPOSTEROUS AND THAT BIG,
IT WAS JUST, LIKE, WOW.
TODAY, YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO DO
A SHOOT FOR VENUS VIBRANCE,
SO, THE FIRST POWERED
RAZOR FOR WOMEN.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA SHOOT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE JUNGLE,
SO THE ONLY WAY TO GET TO
OUR LOCATION IS ON AN ELEPHANT.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
TAKE THESE HARNESSES
OFF THE ELEPHANTS' BACKS
AND YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA BE
POSING WITH THE ELEPHANTS.
ISN'T THAT EXCITING?
- WOW.
- YES!
I AUTOMATICALLY START TRYING
TO THINK ABOUT POSES
THAT I COULD DO 'CAUSE I NEED
MORE VARIETY IN MY POSES.
DANIELLE,
WHAT IS THAT FACE ABOUT?
- THEY'RE HUGE.
- THEY'RE GENTLE.
(elephant trumpets)
NOW, BY THE WAY,
WHEN WE GO THROUGH THIS JUNGLE,
THEY'RE GONNA TILT
AND HEAVE AND HO.
OH, MY GOD. I'M JUST GONNA PUT
THIS SEAT BELT ON.
DANIELLE, IT IS NOT THAT BAD.
WELCOME TO THE JUNGLE.
PLEASE GET SOME WATER.
HAIR AND MAKE-UP'S GONNA
BE OVER HERE,
SO GET SOMETHING TO DRINK FIRST.
I THINK I'VE HAD TO WORK
A LITTLE HARDER
THAN THE REST OF THE GIRLS
JUST TRYING TO BE MORE GRACEFUL.
I CANNOT LET THIS SLIP OUT
OF MY FINGERS.
OKAY, ANOTHER THING.
TODAY, YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
IS PONGSAK TANGTIWAJA.
HE'S A VERY WELL-KNOWN
THAI PHOTOGRAPHER.
- HI, GIRLS.
- HERE ARE YOUR GIRLS.
THE WHOLE IDEA OF THE SHOOT
IS TO CONTRAST YOUR SMOOTH LEGS
WITH THE ROUGH SKIN
OF THE ELEPHANT.
SO WHAT'S REALLY COOL
ABOUT THE VENUS VIBRANCE,
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE JUNGLE,
IT'S BATTERY-POWERED.
THIS IS A TOTALLY NEW
SHAVING EXPERIENCE
THAT WILL INSTANTLY REVEAL
MORE RADIANT SKIN.
WE'VE SET UP A LITTLE
SHAVING STATION OVER THERE,
SO IF YOU COULD HEAD OVER THERE
AND START SHAVING YOUR LEGS.
THEY'RE SMOOTH.
IT'S NICE.
NICE AND SHAVED,
NO STUBBIES.
SO I KNOW YOU DON'T FEEL
REALLY GOOD RIGHT NOW.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW, LIKE,
JUST SAY, I'VE REACHED MY LIMIT,
ALL RIGHT?
THE ONLY THING THAT'S KEEPING ME
GOING RIGHT NOW IS MY DRIVE.
I REALLY WANT TO SELL
YOUR LEGS IN THIS SHOT.
I NEED YOU TO KEEP IN MIND,
I WANT THIS TO BE
A STRONG FASHION POSE.
♪♪♪
(elephant trumpets)
JUST HOLD ON, DANIELLE,
IT'S OKAY.
WHEN THE CAMERA GOES OFF,
THE ELEPHANT GETS NERVOUS.
SHE STARTS MOVING,
AND SHE DOESN'T WANT T
O SIT STILL.
AND I'M SITTING HERE LIKE,
I'M ABOUT TO REGURGITATE
ON SOMEBODY'S FACE RIGHT NOW.
(elephant trumpets)
SHE'S GONNA REACT
TO A FEW FLASHES, BUT THIS IS--
SHE'LL GET USED TO IT.
JUST-- KEEP TRYING
TO WORK WITH IT.
I IMMEDIATELY FEEL REALLY
CURIOUS ABOUT,
HOW IS EVERYONE ELSE DOING
AND KIND OF LEARN
FROM THE OTHER GIRLS.
LIKE A PRO, I LOVE IT.
I LOVE YOUR
BODY LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOU'RE KIND
OF ANIMALISTIC
ON TOP OF THE ELEPHANT.
PRETTY.
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
LAST FRAME.
GOOD JOB, DANIELLE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT MY PHOTOS
ARE GONNA LOOK LIKE.
JAY SAID I DID A GOOD JOB,
BUT I WAS NOT FEELING IT AT ALL.
DANIELLE WAS A LITTLE ILL,
BUT YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU MODEL
AND YOU TRAVEL,
YOU GOTTA LOOK YOUR BEST
ON THESE SHOOTS NO MATTER WHAT.
AND I'M JUST READY,
I'M READY TO ROCK.
I'LL ALWAYS REMEMBER THIS.
SHOOTING WITH AN ELEPHANT
THAT REMINDS ME
OF AN ANCIENT DINOSAUR,
'CAUSE THEY ARE IN
THE DINOSAUR FAMILY.
STROKE YOUR LEG.
COME UP TOWARDS YOUR KNEE,
BUT LEAN FORWARD.
YOU'RE LEANING BACK WITH IT,
I WANT YOU TO BRING YOUR ARM UP,
BUT LEAN FORWARD.
YEAH, LIKE YOU'RE CARESSING
YOUR LEGS, YOUR SMOOTH LEGS.
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IT
TOO MUCH.
IT SHOULD FEEL
VERY NATURAL AND FLUID.
NO, NO.
OKAY, FORGET IT,
DO SOMETHING ELSE.
SORRY.
WHEN YOU GIVE HER DIRECTION,
SHE INSTANTLY BECOMES STIFF,
AND SHE FEELS LIKE MAYBE
IT'S ALMOST A CRITIQUE.
LAST FRAME.
SO THAT'S YOUR LAST SHOT.
JADE WAS VERY STIFF.
I ALSO DON'T THINK SHE WAS
REALLY COMFORTABLE WITH
WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
YOU LOOKED GORGEOUS,
I THINK YOU DID REALLY GOOD.
I KNOW YOU STRESS OUT A LOT.
READY, FURONDA?
READY TO GET UP THERE
AND WORK IT?
I HAVE A CHANCE
TO PROVE MYSELF AGAIN,
SO IN MY MIND, I'M THINKING,
PHOTO SHOOT, ANOTHER CHANCE.
FURONDA LOOKED BEAUTIFUL,
BUT AS SOON AS FURONDA FELT
THAT SHE HAD TO POSE,
SHE TURNED HER JAW INTO IT,
SHE GOT STIFF.
CHIN DOWN.
LET ME SHOW
YOU SOMETHING, FURONDA.
IF YOU'RE THE LENS,
OKAY, YOU DO THIS.
AND I KNOW YOU'VE GOT
A BETTER POSE IN YOU.
I NEED YOU TO--
YOU'RE DOING IT AGAIN.
GIVE ME SOMETHING
THAT'S DIRECT, PRETTY.
(elephant trumpets)
FURONDA, I THINK SHE KIND OF
IS ONE OF THE WEAKEST LINKS.
JAY WAS JUST LIKE,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
SOFT EXPRESSION, PRETTY.
LAST SHOT, BEAUTIFUL.
THAT LAST SHOT WAS GENIUS.
WHEN YOU GET IT, FURONDA,
IT'S GENIUS.
WILL YOU TELL HIM
WHAT I SAID ABOUT THE LEG?
OKAY.
I FELT A LOT OF PRESSURE
BECAUSE IT IS ONLY FIVE GIRLS.
I REALLY WANTED TO FOCUS ON
DOING THE BEST POSES.
OH, WORK, GIRL.
OKAY NOW.
THERE YOU GO, SHOOT IT.
EVEN REST YOUR ARM ON
THE ELEPHANT, THERE YOU GO.
CHIN DOWN, THERE YOU GO,
THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE,
FOR TRYING SOMETHING NEW, OKAY.
BEAUTIFUL.
(laughing)
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE,
SHE CRAWLS UP THE REAL WAY.
OH!
OH, BEAUTIFUL, I LOVE THAT.
CHIN DOWN A BIT.
THERE YOU GO.
YES!
LOOK--
OH, I LOVE THAT.
I DON'T REALLY PAY MUCH
ATTENTION TO JOANIE.
SHE'S NOT ON MY LEVEL.
YOU BETTER WORK, BITCH.
I FEEL LIKE I'M JANICE.
SOMEHOW YOU HAVE GOT
SOME MAGIC WITH THAT ELEPHANT.
JOANIE ROCKED IT OUT,
AND SHE WAS SO CREATIVE.
GOING AFTER HER MOTIVATED ME
TO TRY AND MATCH
THAT SORT OF ENERGY.
I WANTED TO START DOING
A LITTLE BIT OF THE THING
THAT JOANIE JUST DID.
SHE'S GONNA START OFF,
TRYING TO DO THE SAME FOOT THING
THAT JOANIE DID,
SO SHE'S BASICALLY
BITING HER IDEA.
SARA SAW WHAT JOANIE DID.
SARA, OBVIOUSLY BEING
A VERY INTELLIGENT GIRL,
SAW MY REACTION TO JOANIE.
CHIN DOWN A BIT,
THERE YOU GO.
BUT SARA DIDN'T REALLY
EXECUTE IT
IN NEARLY THE SAME GRACEFUL
FASHION THAT JOANIE DID.
IN MODELING, YOU GOTTA MAKE
YOUR SHOTS YOUR OWN.
(laughing)
CHIN DOWN A BIT.
DEFINITELY HARDER
THAN IT LOOKS TO--
WELL, ACTUALLY,
IT PROBABLY LOOKS PRETTY HARD.
SARA COPIES ME,
AND IT'S GETTING ON MY NERVES.
I DON'T WANT TO HELP
ANYBODY ELSE OUT.
ARCH INTO THAT.
CHIN DOWN, THERE YOU GO.
I GOT SOME KIND OF POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE FEEDBACK FROM JAY.
I'M HOPING THAT IT'LL BE
A REALLY GOOD PICTURE.
GOOD JOB.
THAT'S A WRAP.
THAT WAS SO MUCH FUN.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY FOUR WILL CONTINUE ON IN
THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THIS HAS GOTTEN US READY
FOR THE REAL MODELING WORLD
'CAUSE IT'LL NEVER BE THIS HARD.
WE ARE, LIKE,
THE CREAM OF THE CROP,
AND EVERYONE HAD A GREAT SHOT,
SO I THINK
IT'S GONNA COME DOWN
TO HOW OUR PERSONALITY SHINES
IN FRONT OF PANEL.
I AM A THREAT,
AND I KNOW A LOT OF THE GIRLS
ARE INTIMIDATED
AND THEY SEE THAT.
SO IF I DO GO,
THEY'RE GONNA BE HAPPY
BECAUSE THEY'RE LIKE,
"OH, WE DON'T HAVE TO DEAL
WITH JADE ANYMORE."
THAT JOANIE THING,
LIKE, TRYING SOMETHING
THAT SOMEONE ELSE DID.
LIKE, I WAS LIKE,
THAT LOOKS REALLY COOL.
ISN'T THAT, LIKE,
A FORM OF FLATTERY?
SINCE YOU WERE
RIGHT AFTER JOANIE,
IT MADE IT LOOK LIKE YOU WAS
JUST BITING, LIKE, REAL BAD.
I THOUGHT IT'D BE FUN
TO BALANCE ON AN ELEPHANT'S FOOT
FOR ONCE IN MY LIFE,
YOU KNOW?
I FEEL LIKE I AM STILL LEARNING
AND STILL KIND OF
PUTTING PIECES TOGETHER.
WE'RE, LIKE,
ALMOST AT THE FINISH LINE.
LIKE, WE CAN SEE
THE FINISH LINE.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TYRA'S GONNA SAY ABOUT
THE THAI CHALLENGE WITH ME
HAVING TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
I DON'T KNOW WHO IT IS,
BUT SOMEONE'S GOING HOME.
DON'T GIVE UP.
IT AIN'T OVER UNTIL
TYRA DOES NOT CALL YOUR NAME.
♪♪♪
- HELLO, LADIES.
- HELLO.
FIVE BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT ONE GIRL'S GONNA
HAVE TO GO HOME TONIGHT.
YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL MODELING
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER, GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND IT'S TIME TO INTRODUCE
THESE LOVELY JUDGES HERE.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
MISS J. ALEXANDER, RUNWAY DIVA,
TEACHER EXTRAORDINAIRE,
FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND, TWIGGY.
HELLO.
AND SIRI UDOMRITTHIRUJ.
SHE IS THE GROUP PUBLISHING
DIRECTOR OF "ELLE" THAILAND.
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR JUDGING CHALLENGE.
SO FURONDA, THIS WEEK,
YOU LEARNED HOW IT'S IMPORTANT
AS A MODEL TO EXPRESS YOURSELF
THROUGH YOUR BODY.
FOR YOUR JUDGING TEST,
I'D LIKE YOU TO EXPRESS THREE
EMOTIONS USING ONLY YOUR BODY.
LOOK IN THE BOX THERE.
YOU SEE WHY YOU CAN'T
USE YOUR FACE?
- YES.
- SO PUT THAT ON.
FURONDA, I WANT YOU TO CONVEY
THREE EMOTIONS USING YOUR BODY.
THE FIRST EMOTION.
OH, WAIT.
I DIDN'T GIVE IT TO YOU YET.
OH!
WHICH EMOTION WAS THAT?
- PANIC.
- (squeals)
ALL RIGHTY,
THE FIRST EMOTION: SENSUALITY.
THE SECOND EMOTION: DESPAIR.
(laughing)
THE THIRD EMOTION: COMPASSION.
ALL RIGHTY,
FURONDA.
SO FURONDA.
OH, THERE YOU GO.
TADA.
I THOUGHT YOUR "SENSUALITY"
WAS "OUCH."
THE GOOD THING ABOUT YOU
WAS THAT YOU CAME WITH
A GREAT SENSE OF SPIRIT,
HIGH ENERGY, AND YOU KNOW WHAT,
IT MADE ME LAUGH.
YOU JUST DID ANYTHING.
I COULD HAVE SAID,
DO THE "POOMPOOKALAKA."
REMEMBER, TYRA, WE DIDN'T
EVEN ASK ANYTHING,
AND SHE JUST WENT RIGHT INTO IT
BEFORE SHE WAS EVEN INSTRUCTED,
EVEN ASKED.
I WAS JUST THINKING EMOTIONS.
ALL RIGHTY, FURONDA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE
ON TOP OF AN ELEPHANT
AND THE IDEA WAS
TO SHOW OFF YOUR LEGS.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
- WOW.
- THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THE LEGS COULD BE
A LITTLE MORE ELEGANT, MAYBE.
LET'S SEE THE FACE.
HONESTLY, I THINK YOU NAILED.
I MEAN, THE WHOLE SHOT
LOOKS REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
I'M GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM
AND I'M LIKE, DAMN, OKAY!
OKAY, OKAY.
OH, LORD.
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY MEDIUM.
IT'S GREAT AND HORRIBLE.
FROM A MAGAZINE POINT
OF THE VIEW.
IF YOU'RE ALL OVER THE PLACE,
THEN IT WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THE STYLIST TO--
TO CONTINUE TO USE YOU
OVER AND OVER.
- THANKS, FURONDA.
- THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTY, SARA.
I THOUGHT THAT
YOU WERE THE ONE TO ME
THAT GOT EACH EMOTION
VERY CLEAR,
BUT YOU WEREN'T MODELING.
WERE YOU THINKING MODEL, OR--
I WASN'T ACTUALLY
THINKING MODEL.
JUST A LITTLE MEMO,
THIS IS A MODELING COMPETITION.
ALL RIGHT, SARA, HERE IS
YOUR BEST SHOT.
- I LOVE THE LEG EXTENSION.
- BEAUTIFUL.
YOU USED
YOUR WHOLE BODY IN THE SHOT
AND IT DOESN'T LOOK GANGLY
AND IT DOESN'T--
YOU DON'T LOOK UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU USED TO LOOK
SLIGHTLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU REALLY GOT THAT THE SHOOT
WAS ABOUT THE LEGS,
BUT JAY SAID THAT YOU COPIED
SOME OF JOANIE'S ORIGINAL POSES
AND DIDN'T MAKE THEM YOUR OWN.
IF YOU WERE GONNA DO THAT,
YOU WOULD HAVE TO TAKE IT
TO SUCH A LEVEL
THAT JUST KNOCKS
THE SOCKS RIGHT OFF OF HER SHOT.
THE PHRASE IS STEAL
FROM THE BEST
AND MAKE IT YOUR OWN.
OKAY.
JADE.
HOW IS COMPASSION THIS?
IT WAS LIKE THAI DANCING.
WHEN YOU COME HERE,
WE DON'T EXPECT YOU TO DO
YOUR TEACHES AND CHALLENGES
AND STUFF IN HERE,
IT'S INCORPORATING
THAT INTO BEING A MODEL
AND I DIDN'T SAY IT ON PURPOSE,
I DIDN'T SAY
"BUT MAKE SURE YOU'RE A MODEL."
THAT'S PART OF THE TEST.
ALL RIGHT, JADE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
- OKAY.
- CAN WE GET CLOSER?
WELL, IT'S QUITE AWKWARD,
ISN'T IT?
IT'S ALMOST AS IF
YOU'RE FLYING LIKE SUPERWOMAN
AND YOU'VE BEEN PLACE ON TOP
OF THE ELEPHANT.
I WAS DOING A VARIETY OF THINGS.
BUT YOU CAN SEE YOUR LEGS
LOOK VERY PECULIAR THERE.
IT'S THE LEFT LEG.
AND IT'S 'CAUSE YOUR FOOT'S
NOT POINTED.
I THINK YOUR FILM, JADE,
WAS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT IT WAS VERY STIFF.
IT WAS VERY THIS.
IF YOU JUST WANT TO RELAX IT
JUST A LITTLE BIT,
IT COULD HAVE BEEN MORE ELEGANT.
SHE JUST DISMISSED HERSELF.
SHE'S LIKE, THAT'S BAD,
OH, LORD.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
THE FIRST ONE DIDN'T LOOK
LIKE SENSUALITY TO ME,
IT LOOKED LIKE, COLD.
I READ THE EMOTIONS,
BUT THAT IT WAS IN
THE THAI MOVEMENT.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY YOU
WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER,
BECAUSE YOU UNDERSTAND
THOSE THAI MOVES,
SO CONGRATULATIONS FOR BEING
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
BUT YOU GOTTA TAKE THAT
CHALLENGE AND BRING IT IN HERE
AND MAKE IT A MODEL.
SO LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID
IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
WELL, I MUST SAY.
SARA, NO, NO, GIRL.
WOMP, WOMP.
IF YOU MADE THAT ATTEMPT.
I JUST DID THE FOOT ONE,
THE FOOT POSE.
JOANIE,
IT'S FABULOUS, IT'S WONDERFUL.
YOU DO GREAT THINGS
WITH YOUR LEGS.
YOU HAVE CONSISTENTLY DONE,
I THINK, GREAT PICTURES.
FOR SOMEONE WITH SUCH VIVID BODY
LANGUAGE IN YOUR PHOTOGRAPHS,
I CAN'T SAY IT ENOUGH.
YOU'VE GOT TO
BRING THIS IN PERSON.
CAN YOU TAKE THAT GRAY OFF,
JOANIE?
IT'S MAKING YOU
LOOK LIKE MY STOMACH.
THERE YOU GO.
NOW YOU LOOK LIKE A WOMAN,
LIKE A YOUNG LADY.
CAN WE SEE A CLOSE-UP?
IT'S BEAUTIFUL,
STUNNING PICTURE ALL AROUND,
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THIS SHOT.
SO WHEN YOU WALK INTO
YOUR NEXT CASTING,
STRIKE THAT POSE.
WELL, NOT EXACTLY THAT POSE.
- (laughing)
- THANK YOU, JOANIE.
DANIELLE.
I THOUGHT I WAS
GETTING ATTACKED.
I ALMOST RAN BACK.
BUT I LIKED IT,
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING
AS IF I WAS A PHOTOGRAPHER.
TO ME, YOU WERE DANCING,
BUT YOU WERE GOING LIKE THIS...
CLICK.
SNAP.
AS OPPOSED TO...
YOU KNOW, BUT THERE'S NOTHING
TO CAPTURE.
WHAT WERE YOU GUYS THINKING
UNDERNEATH THE MASKS?
WELL, SEE, ME,
I DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO DANCE
BECAUSE I WAS IN THE HOSPITAL,
THE IV, OXYGEN IN THE NOSE.
DEHYDRATION, EXHAUSTION,
AND A LITTLE BIT
OF FOOD POISONING.
DANIELLE, YOU'RE KIND OF
HIGH-MAINTENANCE, AREN'T YOU?
ALL RIGHTY,
YOU MISSED YOUR TEST,
BUT YOU DID THE PHOTO SHOOT
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW, I THINK IT'S BRILLIANT.
I THINK, CONSIDERING THAT
YOU WERE IV'D AND OXYGEN.
I WAS WOOZY UP THERE,
SO I WAS FOCUSING.
I DO SEE THE WOOZY A LITTLE BIT.
THE WOOZY SUITS YOUR FACE,
'CAUSE YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
I DIDN'T SEE SICK,
I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING.
I HAVE A STOMACH CONDITION
AND IT IS THE WORST PAIN
IN THE WORLD,
BUT I JUST HAVE
TO MODEL THROUGH IT
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU DID,
DANIELLE.
- FASHION HAS NO MERCY.
- THEY DON'T.
THANK YOU, DANIELLE.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
WE'VE GOT A LOT TO TALK ABOUT
BECAUSE EVERYONE HAD
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
JADE.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS ACTUALLY
JADE'S BEST LOOK FOR ME.
SHE LOOKS VERY TIGHT
IN THESE PICTURES.
THIS SHOOT REMINDS ME
OF THE DANCE COMPETITION
IN WHICH SHE SHOWED
SUCH TENSION.
IN THE BEGINNING,
I WASN'T TOO CRAZY ABOUT HER,
BUT SHE HAS DELIVERED
ONE BEAUTIFUL PICTURE
AFTER THE NEXT FOR ME.
I MEAN, SHE IS VERY PHOTOGENIC,
BUT I THINK SHE FEELS
SHE KNOWS BETTER.
IT'S JADE'S WAY OR THE HIGHWAY.
DANIELLE.
FOR A GIRL WHO WAS SICK,
I THINK SHE DID A VERY,
VERY WONDERFUL, WONDERFUL JOB.
BECAUSE SHE WAS SICK,
SHE DID MISS THE CHALLENGE.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
STRIKE SOMEBODY DOWN
FOR BEING GENUINELY SICK.
DESPITE THE FACT,
SHE TAKES GOOD PICTURES.
DANIELLE STILL IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHEN SHE SPEAKS.
SHE'S GOT TO START
WORKING ON IT.
- A LITTLE LESS GHETTO.
- YEAH, A LITTLE LESS.
JUST SPEAK A LITTLE CLEARER.
JOANIE.
WHEN I SAW HER PERFORMING,
I WAS IMPRESSED.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO PERFORM.
EXCEPT WHEN IT COMES TO JUDGING.
JUDGING IS A TIME WHEN SHE NEEDS
TO BRING OUT THAT LOOK.
FURONDA.
THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL PHOTOGRAPH,
BUT IN PERSON,
SHE'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
SHE JUST DOESN'T QUITE GET IT.
HER CHARM, HER SPIRIT,
HER ENERGY.
I LIKE HAVING HER AROUND.
I SAW FURONDA DOING THAI DANCE,
WHICH WAS INCREDIBLE,
THE WHOLE AUDIENCE
WAS LAUGHING AWAY,
BUT IN TERMS OF GRACE,
IT ALL DISAPPEARED.
WHO KNEW SARA KNEW HOW TO POINT
AND POSE LIKE THIS?
I KIND OF THOUGHT A LITTLE BIT
THAT SHE KIND OF HAD IT IN HER.
I DIDN'T.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS
VERY GOOD TODAY.
I ACTUALLY
QUITE LIKED HER POSING.
SHE TOUCHED ME.
IS IT TOO LITTLE, TOO LATE?
WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
FIVE BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
FOUR PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE FOUR PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE YOUNG LADIES
THAT WILL STILL BE IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL.
JOANIE.
JOANIE, YOU ROCKED THIS WEEK.
LOOK AT THAT PICTURE.
THAT IS A MODEL.
BUT WHAT WE WANT IS A TOP MODEL,
AND THAT APPEARANCE TODAY
WASN'T THAT.
DO THIS IN HERE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME.
SARA.
IF THIS WAS A SPORTING EVENT
AND YOU WERE ON A TEAM,
YOU'D BE MOST IMPROVED.
BUT SARA,
IF YOU'RE GOING TO COPY,
YOU GOTTA MAKE IT YOUR OWN,
BUT MAKE IT BETTER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
DANIELLE.
YOU MAKE SICK LOOK PRETTY.
BUT THE ONE THING THAT
THESE JUDGES STRUGGLE WITH YOU
(mimics Danielle' accent)
IS THIS....
THEY SAY IT EVERY WEEK,
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
AND I'VE TOLD YOU
A COUPLE OF TIMES,
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN IMPROVEMENT.
TOP MODEL'S GOT TO SPEAK,
NOT JUST LOOK PRETTY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WILL FURONDA AND JADE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL BE IN
THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE HOTEL,
PACK HER BELONGINGS
AND FLY HOME.
FURONDA.
THE JUDGES SEE
A GREAT PERSONALITY.
SOMEBODY THAT'S FUN
AND ENDEARING,
BUT SOMEBODY
THAT DOESN'T QUITE GET IT.
TELL HER ONE THING
AND SHE DOES
A WHOLE DIFFERENT THING.
JADE, THE JUDGES JOKE ABOUT IT,
WHEN YOU'RE IN FRONT OF THEM
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"JADE MARCHES TO HER OWN DRUM,
JADE IS JADE."
BUT THEN YOU LEAVE
THE ROOM AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"JADE IS JADE."
AND THEY FEEL LIKE YOU'VE
COME TO YOUR END...
...OF ADAPTING.
JADE, YOU MARCH
TO YOUR OWN DRUM,
BUT IF YOU KNEW EVERYTHING,
JADE,
YOU'D BE A SUPERMODEL ALREADY,
AND THAT HASN'T HAPPENED YET.
AND FURONDA, WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE MARCHING TO.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
CONGRATULATIONS, JADE.
♪♪♪
THANK YOU
FOR BELIEVING IN ME ONCE AGAIN.
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY ME
BELIEVING IN YOU.
BUT IT'S ABOUT YOU
TAKING DIRECTION, JADE.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT YOU
THAT'S JUST LIKE,
I'LL CHANGE A LITTLE
BUT I KNOW BEST.
I KNOW YOU HAVE POTENTIAL, JADE.
DON'T BE YOUR OWN
WORST ENEMY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU, FURONDA.
- THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
WORK IT.
- (laughing)
- OH!
THE JUDGES SAYING THAT
I MARCH TO THE BEAT
OF MY OWN DRUM,
IT'S NOT REALLY
A NEGATIVE FOR ME
BECAUSE THAT'S SOMETHING
I'VE ALWAYS DONE,
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S--
I'M PROBABLY ALWAYS GONNA DO.
OF COURSE I'M SURPRISED
TO BE GOING HOME.
HOW COULD THEY SEND
THE FABULOUS FURONDA HOME?
THE JUDGES MUST HAVE
LOST THEIR HEADS.
I FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT
MAKING IT IN THE FINAL FIVE
BECAUSE I WAS ON THE CHOPPING
BLOCK THE FIRST WEEK OUT.
SO I BEEN KICKING IT IN,
CONSISTENTLY GETTING STRONGER,
SO I'M HAPPY WITH THAT.
Tyra: COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THE GIRLS GEAR UP
FOR SOME UNCONVENTIONAL
GO-SEES.
A PHOTO SHOOT TURNS INTO
TROUBLE IN PARADISE.
YOU DON'T REALIZE
THAT THE GIRL WAS FREEZING.
I THINK SHE SHOULD
COME OFF THERE.
AND JOANIE QUESTIONS SARA'S
COMMITMENT TO THE COMPETITION.
I DON'T THINK
SHE SHOULD BE HERE.
SHE WAS THIS CLOSE
TO BEING A LAWYER.
I FEEL LIKE A BITCH.
♪♪♪